it's Monday July 5th greetings from
podcast Ville the Church of what's
happened now is brought to you by zip
recruiter listen to me
during this time of change we want you
to know that zip recruiters focus hasn't
changed they're still doing what they've
always done helping people find work and
they're helping businesses find the
right people for the job if you're
looking for a job
zip recruiter is working with you to
find the right job faster you understand
me by connecting people who need jobs
and companies that need people
zip recruiter is working with all of us
so we can keep moving forward now let's
work together do me a favor go to zip
recruiter comm slash work together and
get started today
right now who else does that for you
nobody go to CBD line calm right now
press in jerks get this [ __ ] party
started Lee it's Monday the 5th
[ __ ] [ __ ]
we don't like [ __ ] delicious welcome
to church
Monday morning
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive shits crack-a-lackin' had a great
weekend this weekend everything's
beautiful happy 4th of July we didn't
get to see each other on Friday and
talked but I hope you all you
[ __ ] had a happy 4th hopefully
you got all your fingers I know a lot of
[ __ ] are walking around with a
fingers today in the story I'm saying
a lot of [ __ ] walking around
with eight fingers a couple guys is just
all born into death right now
tonight the fuse went too fast I've been
there I've seen fingers flying no biggie
no biggie you'll be all right in about a
year you buy next one in July you'll
learn a new [ __ ] drill yeah you learn
how to throw with the hook yeah I'm
saying and you'll be fine the hook
always works the Firecracker goes
following you did you see that DNA did
you see the aerial footage of La like
next time just [ __ ] tell people yeah
you can't make dick illegal now not
right now now people gonna blow us there
were bombs going off on my house I woke
up this morning was a leg in front a
little Iraqi leg in my house I just do
it in the [ __ ] garbage there was
there were more fireworks in my
neighborhood but like that like like pop
up like a legitimate I lost I was in my
office I thought a bomb went off I
wasn't yeah I thought my family I'm like
you guys all right I will tell you
though July 8th is the best day today
was the best [ __ ] day to go on
YouTube because all you see is drunk
people fighting at barbecues people
holding onto firecracker for too long
and white dudes firing firecrackers out
of their [ __ ] it's the [ __ ] best
day to be on YouTube you see more dudes
with bottle rockets propped up on a
chair yeah today was the day to be on
YouTube you know what else today last
week I did a podcast ready for this one
about with my wife's tonight 20th
anniversary last Wednesday but you know
it's also what this week is it's our
25th anniversary we met July 2nd
1995 this weekend in Seattle in fact it
was the same setup because we did have
an open mic Monday the fourth of July
was sadly and I went down to the
underground I looked in the window I'm
like oh my god I rubbed the brick I'm
like I'm finally here yeah at the
underground [ __ ] and then we had an open
mic Monday you came in with yeah at my
jump right on your dog what's what with
the boss than that yeah yeah yeah I'm
surrounded with all these people with
yarmulkes on [ __ ]
but it's 25 [ __ ] years I know you
know holy [ __ ] I didn't want you to feel
old
but [ __ ] to get my [ __ ] time 125
years you came out of Monday you got to
go back to Lobo local yeah and then I
think we finally Tuesday you hung out
whose days that is crazy 25 years this
week I got no idea was this weird I got
there like Jilla I did the triple soon
when you got there how soon did you make
it down to the underground like how long
had you been in Seattle you got there
didn't ya the truth yeah I did the
triple one on a Saturday night
it had a B I was in LaGrange Oregon with
Carol no I was alone see how far it is
from Lagrange Oregon to Seattle
Washington so you were you were by
yourself
I was by myself my deal was to do a
Tribble run to lead me to Seattle to
drop me off a few hours from see who do
you have any do you remember at all who
you were doing that run with some shitty
[ __ ] oh no no I don't remember his
name but he was a really really really
good guy as a matter of fact he lived
him like Laguna Beach it's about 325
miles so 325 miles divided by 70 miles
an hour was what five hours five hours I
think I did it like three hours because
she was getting out of work at the strip
club at 2:00 and I beat her
to her apartment she left me a key under
the mat yeah and I went in and she came
over from the strip club so that was a
Saturday night at 2:00 yeah how is that
the underground the next day by
lunchtime at attention
yeah man you understand yeah I don't
know I don't know what are you talking
about she's talking about gonna pick big
Pike's Market yeah and it will [ __ ] your
mother in the air let's go see the
underground yes so we took like a
[ __ ] cab down to the underground it
was closed it was lunchtime I was like
[ __ ] and I rubbed the brick I could tell
that there was a bar oh yeah I was like
the bar up slam yeah yeah [ __ ] is this
this is not what was told and how how
had you heard about the open mic on
Monday did you ask somebody at Swami's
because there wasn't like an internet
you were looking at that's closed that
Saturday yeah and it was closed that
Sunday for the fourth of July weekend
God so I called like Monday and Ron
recall back he's like ah to match the
open mic cuz I let all records game is
it
do you remember Rick turns gave me the
he goes when you go up there tell Ron
Reed you're a friend of mine toe box
your friend of mine so I took called Ron
Reed robbery just said go down to the
thing and sign up Carl was there the
best he put me up like number one
because they always put your first now
the first man you win yeah you went up
first host it got fifty bucks
yep fifty bucks how much is fifty bucks
back then a lot when you host on a
Monday and you got 50 bucks come on man
and then my girl had the contest in
Tacoma oh yeah yeah [ __ ] thing at the
coal mine yeah that's how we made a
living Mondays Monday's was our big
living yeah if you won the contest you
want a yardstick and you'd come back to
file on Monday and host but also you
know what else you we did a bunch up
there was we would find we would find
one-nighters that we knew weren't gonna
last but for like two or three months
you got a paycheck to host or whatever
you know what I mean like we we must
have I personally must have star
and failed 15 room at least right I mean
so [ __ ] mad he's so mad losing but
like I still remember you taking me to
an undercooked we used to do it was
pretty much the same [ __ ]
Monday Tuesday was the underground yeah
Wednesday was a Laura Crockett gig one
of those gig Thursday we crashed
somebody's well no Wednesday we started
the underground because Wednesday's it
was still somebody's night yeah so at
least I had had a night sorry week we're
coming down yeah
well coming we did a lot of people yeah
we're coming down on Wednesday night did
you worry about nothing
did any of those guys let you tour with
them up there who tour who took you out
on the road Vince Valenzuela so I got
there on a Monday all right yeah I got
that a Saturday this is how I tell
people like I tell people like listen
when you're dealing with me you're
dealing with the wrong guy like when you
if you come to me and tell me your story
you're dealing with the wrong guy cuz
you're not gonna stop me
yeah so I got down a Saturday at 2:00 in
the morning I was at the underground at
12 the next day which is the Lord's Day
and it was close yeah okay yeah you want
to talk about love for comedy and then I
was back there Monday the open might
start at 8:00 I was there at 7:00 at
attention like [ __ ]
like I was about to go on in Madison
Square Garden I went up Danny told me
come back tomorrow night then I came
back the next night and then Wednesday
somebody turned me on to something
somewhere Ballard yeah Wednesday Valerie
those were the nights that we would find
a place just to [ __ ] if you give us a
hundred and fifty bucks we'll put up
fifteen comics or we'll put up for
comics whatever we can pend again are
you ready for this that Thursday I
already got a call I'm whatever mind you
another story that he's gonna show all
these people at home could remember that
Thursday I already had a call from John
Fox you working Friday and Saturday in
Idaho at that for Moscow Moscow Idaho
and you know who the headliner was wait
Vince valenzuela's get out and they
treated me like a gentleman
he's a good-good dude he's on Facebook
yeah except the messenger while he
didn't hit me back I don't know if he
does comment him he does he does he's a
great job brother to me super nice guy
you did that for you did that gig for 50
bucks
well 75 bucks he mailed you check yeah
yeah you had a drive back from there all
over is [ __ ] cuz they would send you a
prairie fart yeah it's just icky Tabasco
Florida yeah I remember still seeing the
New England Patriot quarterback at the
airport Drew Bledsoe Drew Bledsoe
yeah went for that's cool Washington
State Washington State so it was [ __ ]
crazy because because Moscow is right
across the line from Washington so
Washington State and and what's in
Moscow is what University of Idaho maybe
something like that but so they're right
next to each other so yeah those
Washington State okay I got work before
the first week I already featured
convinced round as well how much I drove
home on [ __ ] Saturday going wow now
it's that easy like I just came up here
yeah and bitch-slapped [ __ ]
into our first week of work that's
[ __ ] crazy okay then me and him were
eating lunch I was eating free lunch at
his bar one day about three or four
weeks laying on me I'm eating [ __ ]
the chicken molé a that was tremendous
that dude made the best [ __ ] I would
just leave him anyways he would give me
like a check and I'm yeah push it away
and his brother with the fake I cuz you
get stabbed in it yeah [ __ ] food I'm
updating you students I'm going home boy
walked in started a fight with me we
gonna member that fight that meant that
day because I went up there with [ __ ]
roller skates on like I was in no mood I
just came from Denver
well no no no no no well you still here
yeah yeah I just came from [ __ ]
Danville where there's no action where I
would drive to [ __ ] Wyoming to do an
open mind you gotta have wrong
[ __ ] you got the wrong guy I
would drive to Wyoming on Thursday
nights to do it open myself stop with
your [ __ ]
so right after that I [ __ ] one other
tab because then our Berto gave me work
the following week yeah at the old
improv The Improv closes yeah that was
right across from right across from
Pike's Martin yep and then we were going
to bar downstairs across the street oh
come on who the [ __ ] you thinking that
was the old Improv Theater I think the
club was The Improv dealer out there
without the Steve McGrew god yeah yeah
yeah yeah so was a theatre that was the
Improv the cross the stream from Pikes
Peak is deja vu oh yeah 50 ugly girls
and one fat one
and then across the street from that is
Pike's Market in those day yeah and
across the street from Pike's Market on
the side was a little bar we used to go
to on the side you could sneak in it was
a white people bar but Rob Wallace yeah
Rob long to take us was a light-skinned
brother married to a white jack good
dude right no I just talked to him a
couple of weeks ago he's dead every time
I see I showed I caught my wife might I
call him Zombo but I call my daughter's
humble he was he was good to you up
there to rot along with really yeah man
he was he was like Rogan yeah he was
like bring it [ __ ] yeah he was good to
you he was like bring it
you're gonna go up there Chloe bring it
yeah I want to follow he was a ready for
solid yeah I still leave a message Edie
what do you think call me back er what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you John yeah man
he was good guy who who was so the first
person to have an Altoid can yeah filled
with the best weed yeah that was grown
and he had good we every time he'd show
up and he treated it like a [ __ ] like
a pot of gold
it was an Altoid can and then he'd fill
up with weed that was just a member
trying to steal a bud from one time he's
like Jody Oz don't think about it cuz we
drove the highway once we drove it
together you did me and him when we
stayed how [ __ ] crazy what year was
that he drove me down to the Latino
laughs festival showcase and you want to
talk about a lucky dude [ __ ]
okay I just mentioned the tab
I got to come up with money for this
festival I got to allow a showcase and
he goes I got to go to Hawaii next week
set up next week and I set it up and he
had a break cuz he was an artist yeah he
used to take picnics [ __ ] yeah he
would take pictures on the road he loved
going on the road because this thing was
to take pictures and then he'd come home
and fill it in with paint and he would
sell them yeah like a big [ __ ] market
for those there before the internet
mm-hmm [ __ ] like he was like a mentor
to me he's taught me how to act how to
crack jokes he was a great writer he had
a bit do you remember his opening joke
that he would do almost everywhere
he would say I was cuz Bellevue was a
super white place and he would always
say I was over and Bill you today at the
mall and I could hear the security guy
behind me go I'm gonna need some help
there's a black guy here who's clearly
not big enough to be a Seahawk or Sonic
that was his he said wherever he was
something I butchered that joke if he's
listening one Sunday but I love to laugh
like comedians I love when a comic
[ __ ] just drove me off Sunday nights
was [ __ ] nights there especially after
football or Mariner game yeah upstairs
would be packed let me ask him we would
have the Seahawks upstairs we would have
the man yo when the Yankees were in town
Yankees yeah he became a New England
Patriot later man he was a Seahawk but
he's I know I'm from Boulder
dude that's away from Boulder him and
Chad brown yeah we I remember going
upstairs and seeing him and I'm going
what up you're here he's like yeah that
was the bar we were at he was out all
the time every night every [ __ ] that
coming out of my nose it's terrible
loose yeah asunder [ __ ] but those are
the people that hung out upstairs
yeah Eddie vana was up there one night
with McDowell Jack McDowell Jack
McDowell I mean it was just a party some
of them used to get behind the bar a bar
tectum Bart
the Filipino bartender who hated me if I
get some coke one night and then he went
off I feel like he started liking me he
started giving me a tab and he started
taking care of me that way
what was the name ramen Billy do you you
can hear Billy laughs good people down
in that kitchen dog it was like do you
remember the weekend it was that Rick
Carnes were in was in talent and was me
you and Rick Carnes and so Friday night
Rick those two shows we all do two shows
together and he crushes and I come down
Saturday and I sit in the green room he
was like I have met you before I'm Rick
I'm like I open for you last night he
goes yeah I don't remember last night me
and Josh opening up for the black dude
that rented the Jaguar and took us to
the strip club and gave us James Stevens
the third James we just Mack she was on
the Stephanie Miller show ah and well
yeah me and Josh like we were in there
Ron Reed so Ron Reed's wife god rest her
soul owes his manager so we'd see Ron
and go Ron we see that I might remember
louis c.k yeah comment like I still move
a Doug Stanhope remember he taped that
louis c.k the stand-up taped a CD my CD
there I stood my my hanging with Mitch
Hedberg addressed the snow yeah [ __ ] he
was a lot with Ramona Ramona right we
had the [ __ ] we had a transvestite
that did querido oh we had a fat black
chick that was hysterical that did call
me we'd have a little black guy what was
his cliff Barnes cliff Barnes was my dog
we the highs down here paralyzed on here
yes reached out a couple yeah we Co we
had this little comedy fan
but one day so I ran away I got word
from our bird oh the Cuban dude he was
kind of gay yeah and by the way we
didn't know for sure
also Brody tango team our aina I mean
this was like yeah so now I get so my
job I was pretty much Moscow Idaho
Alberto I picked up the volcano room oh
yeah that was in the tri-cities yeah
that was like [ __ ] big-time 375 for
the weekend what was the name of the
woman who bought a Richards honor
Richard Starla Richard the book the
volcano room yeah over by Idaho there's
a city by Idaho Spokane something else
and something else it's called the
tri-cities yeah and it mixes well so we
was like a three-hour drive Rodney
Sherwood was the first guy he was my dog
he was way too funny guy you know room
what was the name of the room you and I
and Lennie Schmidt did that wasn't
Roseburg that was Roseburg which was
death that was where the strip club the
DJ that she was the emcee yes she was
the waitress and she was the stripper
yeah and then it was and then the
Chinese restaurant we did was Kowloon's
that's where I sold them for the half
ounce of we're but Kowloon's also had a
restaurant in Eugene that was off the
chain this [ __ ] that wok fried rice
they would fry the rice and then give
you huge slices of [ __ ] barbecued
pork on top bet [ __ ] tremendous
[ __ ] tremendous but so I'm not gonna
roll guys
I what did you ever see The Sopranos
when yeah when the big guy from
Boardwalk Empire gets out of jail and he
goes to see the old guy yeah the guy
that was a Scarface you know I'm not
giving me the names
the guy from Scarface that played the
white deal yeah that Tony kills for
Michelle Pfeiffer he's on the surprise
yeah remember he can't hide jail and
there's one scene where he gives him an
envelope and [ __ ] the guy from
Boardwalk Empire goes what's this
he goes you just got a week ago and he
goes bro I came out I hit the ground
running like when you come on you hit
the ground running you don't look back
and then when I went to Seattle like I
was like I'm not here to make friends
I'm here to become a way better comic so
I went out of town like I got
everybody's phone numbers yeah and from
Monday to Friday in those days on
Mondays you had a fax events you had a
fax avails to Pat Wilson Donna riches
your manager yeah John Fox you had a
that was what you did not Monday - not
Monday at 11:00 not Monday at 9:30
Monday at 8:59 how many I was already at
the store because at 9:00 I was on the
phone with the guy from giggles uh okay
so that was my work what's his name and
I was snorting blow back there I was
doing it all I don't wanna hear those
stories yeah that's why I love people
like come on yeah well nothing's
happened no I went to Seattle and I hit
the ground running so hard in the month
of July that like I'm in August I'm
already in July I got the underground I
was supposed to leave I was supposed to
stay in see yeah yeah that's what nobody
doesn't know I was supposed to stay I
was supposed to be back in Colorado
August 15 for football season but John
Fox called me and gave me Memorial Day
Labor Day weekend to open up for Laurie
Kilmartin
has a feature act at the underground Shh
everybody can suck my dick in those days
yeah when you feature it at the
underground you were feature yeah that's
it yeah that's it no more I'm saying
bye yeah so I'm gonna go back to Boulder
and get into a fight with my ex-wife or
knock out the boyfriend or go to prison
I got a feature I just let life
contradict I did not know pretty good
like that I didn't know you were
supposed to go in Augie
yeah no I left it in God's hands what I
want to see out I put it in God's hands
I said
you tell me what you want me to do I got
a daughter and Boulder they don't want
me she doesn't want me around I'm gonna
end up going to jail you let me know
what you want me to do and every weekend
in Seattle boom
Donna Richard boom Pat Wilson boom Omar
the gay guy whenever is Alberto yeah you
know then [ __ ] he called me you know
John Fox call me what are you doing
Labor Day and I'm like I want to offer
you this weekend I'm doing it yeah that
was it that was a hell yeah I said where
the [ __ ] am I gonna go I was fighting
for my life in baldon I was living in
the rocky apartment doing six spots a
week driving 22 hours a week here just
on Tuesday and went Monday I got three
spots yeah cuz then you started taking
me to a place when the lip worked
yeah yeah yeah yeah dad cages and we
went up he said come to calm oh there
was there was Birds there was no no no
no not the bird place across this was
still a Seattle oh we used to have to
get in the car and make go the street
going into the underground came this way
yeah we would have to make a left and go
up that side and go up a little bit and
then you went up then it was like a cool
hip yeah you went downstairs and there
was girls dancing cages and we'll it was
a nice guy he active Damon like if you
had a [ __ ] bar you like yeah there
was no Mike there was nothing there was
no like did you tell anybody why they
call it no no it's me you and like we
like gang sanrak the place but it was
like six okay haven't always gave us an
8 bucks
let me get six beers
oh you guys want mugs
no there's six of us were the comics and
we're doing beer won't be here we
hurried dollars pop video and then was
like look at this like what the [ __ ] are
these gorillas dude
so we went like the lip used to get
these huge sores on his lip it was mixed
with like Seattle juice runs I had never
seen anything like that on somebody's
body there were these massive and they
end and he never mentioned it
and he just you just talk to him like if
it blows up I hope it doesn't hit me in
the mouth never even mentioned it and he
was good look at this [ __ ] yeah man
that's what it was he had herpes from
swinging dick yeah you know he had
herpes from swinging dick and by the way
that huge thing on his lip never stopped
him from picking up well now he would
pick up things he'd make up with him he
was like sweet Big Willy
he wouldn't even he he was that good
luck that he he was that good-looking
guys and he we I'll never forget the
first time we showed up and he's like
all right he's like who's going up first
I'm like are you gonna turn the music
off yeah like it was like [ __ ] like
you like crazy music hmm it wasn't a
Roger captain it was like white people
like make-believe white people like you
know it was a lounge and [ __ ] we're not
just gonna walk up there he's I can
gob-dan I'm a Mike three of us one up
all three of us ain't a bag of dicks and
then we had a laugh with talk with him
no he listen we'll come up here but you
gotta set a lot price yeah you can't
just hang is coming here we go music now
turn the music off you gotta let people
all this comedy these are not how many
people these are beautiful people you
know those people like that beautiful
people like there that minks on in July
[ __ ] like that those are the type of
people they are there's nothing worse
than staying in front of a room of
people who
no they're going to see comment no
didn't know because they don't well that
that's the last thing you never want to
be surprised with the stand-up if you
want to go see stand-up you [ __ ] go
see stand up so right away people were
like what the [ __ ] is this and the music
was going and the girls were dancing it
was it was a no-win but the were the
worst no when we ever had
do you remember that place I think it
was in Kirkland I had the birds and the
and be on stage he was huge
anyway he would chip on [ __ ] he'd beaten
and the microphone would you know for
you guys think that comedies like this
[ __ ] luxurious cry oh my god it
really is it's the first couple years a
couple years if your first ten year if
you don't have a sense of humor you are
not going to me know like Felicia told
me a story one time with her Shannon go
to New York to showcase and she had no
money and Dennis Larry said you could
stay at my apartment I don't stay in
there and that she went there was the
dead of winter and the window was broken
and that there was no blanket that she
had to lay on the floor and the window
was broken yeah and she's like this is
coming this is what I chose I go did you
feel bad were you scared she goes no and
then I got an hour into the night what's
his name for The Tonight Show open the
door that he's the book he was like a
regular comic well he she said he didn't
know I was staying there so he came over
one night and that's how they became
friends the guy that said girls aren't
funny I used the book let on him
yeah I know that's how I met him was a
Denis Leary's apartment she's talking
like 1989 Elena something like that like
you know so these are the stories yeah
that everybody thinks it's like this
flopped in I still remember there would
nights if I didn't if I got caught in
Seattle and [ __ ] around I would miss
the last bus tear out some belly mm-hmm
and I would have to sleep at [ __ ] Lowe's
house which was a pleasure also close
how you never knew what is gonna happen
in a second there you go oh yeah oh yeah
I said that's that [ __ ] his real milk
his eyes haven't been open in his last
words I mean but what the yeah I mean
you get please get food on his shirt oh
my god we got [ __ ] up last night my
wife found an apple core and the blank
in the living room now she said what you
got this one's because I've gotta fold a
blanket and there's an apple core what
the [ __ ] did you do last night
because what did you drink I made a
protein shake I had a couple [ __ ]
apples back dog at night I'm on a
different level and you gotta remember I
hate what Lee ate yesterday plus a
hundred milligram tube of quickies with
the guy that I gave a tube to he's still
[ __ ] okay he called me something you
got me oh my god what happened right
after you left he gave a tube I wonder
what I like for any afternoon I'm bored
as [ __ ] I'm about to die this is the
worst fourth of July Saturday that was
the worst day on the way that was the
worst thing I've ever suffered to I love
[ __ ] people up you ABS you takes you
[ __ ] a certain holidays
holidays days and hours just Saturday
it's 6:00 I'm gonna lose my wife has a
friend and the kid wanted to come over
and play with mercy so we agreed to ride
bikes so we rode bikes for [ __ ] two
hours and we would have to stop every
like 15 minutes and [ __ ] talk it's
not my fourth of July yeah cut out for
that [ __ ] you know I'm gonna talk to you
the more I know you didn't shout yeah I
know you didn't shower and you want to
talk to me about what you know so I'm
really I thought it was just the worst
water dry ever one of them didn't we got
home at 3:30
my wife knew just by looking at me I
took the bike I hope to carry this [ __ ]
in I took my bank I put it in the back I
went to look at the weave and I had like
1/8 left of some dynamite [ __ ] I did two
bong hits and I'm like this isn't gonna
be enough if I am so bored on the 4th of
July I'm gonna [ __ ] cry but there's
only one thing I could do to stop you
from crying like I'm just gonna load up
on edibles so I went over to urban trees
I bought two quickies
what's a quickie what these is a tube
it's a hundred milligram it's like a
5-hour energy drink oh yes like 500 you
but they have an indica sativa I found
that ABX which I love has a sweeping
blend like what the [ __ ] you talking I
know if I take two of these I'd sleep
walking sleeping yeah yeah I don't even
know Thai with the urban trees I go what
the [ __ ] is this they haven't like I'm
25 or 50 milligrams that must be perfect
that'll kill somebody
yeah so what that doing is now is
they're putting like melatonin CBN
[ __ ] the other [ __ ] route
I drink a teeth that stream milligrams
yeah a day you [ __ ] to drink it
Jacomo teeth can read milligram three
milligrams of THC three milligrams of
THC three milligrams of CBN not CBB what
CBN cut your legs off the wobbling shits
like you got punched in the head and how
do I know because I overdose on that
[ __ ] every night I only drink I don't
drink one tea bag I do three ok so
that's 9 milligrams of THC CBN and like
everything else I just told you about
yeah
melatonin [ __ ] get akinesia root and
I think that put you to sleep it's all
put into one thing that's brilliant
that is the most brilliant thing I ever
heard you sleep through the night oh you
will sleep during the night and during
the day you know you'll sleepwalk and
here's the thing that people do not know
the one thing I always avoid like well I
have a lot of anxiety
the doctor prescribed a little white
ones mm-hmm and those little white ones
don't do the I like I don't take him at
night because you can't sleep on you
sleep at me you can't take that that's a
big no-no and people don't know that you
can't take sleep aids when you have
sleep apnea then you rest too much and
you'll [ __ ] die and a friend of ours
died yeah there's a comedian who died
too bad to sleep out in here taking
xanax and drink it and didn't use a
machine and he died so I made it a habit
but that don't CBD things like CBD from
CBD line yeah if I do the two thousand
milligrams under my tongue it takes me a
long a time
it's an hour till I fall asleep but when
I hit I'm in your head your head you in
are you know I'm saying so when you take
all that [ __ ] and sprinkle 100
milligrams of THC in it and not just hug
they put 99 into people at the legal
level okay because you can't sell
hundred milligrams so they are you how
long you hi okay so let's talk let's
talk to my Karthik see this [ __ ] but
he gets up at 3:00 look he's still high
from last night he's I know boys coming
in do you know them saying like I know
what type of damn gonna happen I prepare
my day mentally I prepare all ready for
tomorrow I know what I'm gonna do what I
can do it I can't do it I gotta be at
the gym yes yes so I have an appointment
so I know but after that I'm loose
economy store since a loose it's not
like I have to stay sober anymore by the
way you just perfectly described my
entire time you don't have to there's
nowhere to be super loose this is the
time to do everyone whatever the [ __ ]
you want to do this is the time I told
you I've been takin a bunch of mushrooms
oh this is the time super loose so if
you're gonna go go yeah now I was so
[ __ ] bored on the 4th of July I was
about to kill somebody there was not a
soul on the streets of California not a
soul
I walked into the weed store I was like
Frankenstein like so they just stack me
up I said listen it's a bad day the
chicks like Emily putting quickies and
then she put two things of bills I don't
know what they call oh they're a
complete different level the last time I
gave it to him he's like a them like
eight minutes Vegas I feel he's already
right they just go off and you are they
the same type no they're like little
[ __ ] pills they come ten in the
container to twenty-five milligrams
apiece you look down hard so yeah I
bought two
canisters of quickies - canisters of
those no no I got these everywhere yes I
got these everywhere so I [ __ ] was
driving on Lancashire my saw my boys in
there by himself my god can I let him
what kind of gentleman in my I tell him
said a man said by himself on the 4th of
July so I made the u-turn I go back I
wanted there with both tubes of my head
yeah he was like even like five guys no
he was eating them Jersey Mike's he said
how you doing like oh good I got brought
you a present
here's what is that go ahead up because
I I gotta how you ask in the back and I
just open it you don't ask people you
don't you don't say nothing you just
open it you [ __ ] stick a key in the
top and you give it to him
that's it's like a Ben Franklin clothes
franklin clothes they turn around they
put a pen they turn around whoever talks
first loses
so I gave him the bottom he just looked
at it and he goes what's in this what do
you think of this
just check it I popped mine and I went
all the way back like [ __ ] like I was
on the Titanic and I saw him go like
three cords it was about 3:30 yeah
so I sat there with him talk about 10:00
to 4:00 at 10:00 to 4:00 I said I gotta
go
I had been torturing him for bias it's
about 9:00 the more yeah I'm coming over
you're on fire drink milk cuz I still
got the thousand milligram brownies the
what thousand milligram brownies look
look at the look on his face he's like
jerk that you eat hummus I see the food
you eat no this is fine
this is way better than the food you eat
those communist at burger the frozen
patty ones they even in jail you eat
better
I still got thousand milligrams all
those things you eat a whole one of
those
you have no idea listen back it was
that's not [ __ ] Sara Lee yeah no I
get it but you get a glass of milk yeah
no I can dip it in there you dope it up
you force your way tastes great
it just tastes like weed with chemicals
in it like having my animal trained yeah
yeah no big listen we're spoiled by the
way edibles taste right when they when
they first came out they all tasted like
that but then they every single one
without the house I'm gonna make tonight
maybe I make some hash cookies oh yeah I
had some real nice hash no when i jus he
probably some real [ __ ] ass does he
have a patch he's got a big suck more
than anybody I told lately we should
just take your eye out because you ain't
getting no [ __ ] what guys with my
badges getting [ __ ] what I just get
[ __ ] he gets [ __ ] so he brought me
over this Egyptian ass guys it's not
fire this shit's on fire real Ida stops
no it's too much for you I'm gonna eat
it Bruce Lee used to eat that [ __ ] in
that time and Hollywood they used to
make sugar cookies me and Ralphie used
to you know hash is it different
yeah when you eat hash alone and you
wake up or you're 18 massages everything
is loose I think I'm gonna eat that ass
tonight Jack when I get home wait are
you gonna cook it up I'm gonna cook it
up and put a little something tonight
tonight maybe make like a chicken noodle
soup is not what I thought you were
gonna say right that down what are you
melt it down in butter melted with a
little butter
yeah just take it drip it wait till it
take melts and tight that black little
paste
yeah you put that right into the cookies
Oh sometime I told the hobo that day but
the rest yeah so I give a damn it I
leave at 10:00 to 4:00 I got can't
torture leave until I know he's fully
tortured so my fourth day they start
fooling my boy
so it's 4:30
I left a do 40 minutes ago call him up
and check it out of being the edge of
the phone yeah for third they call him
again at 5:00 he didn't pick up
that's one down now I got this page of
the work huh so I call him up he's like
I mean come on bring it [ __ ]
he says challenging me and [ __ ] Lee hmm
he's like bring a [ __ ]
I'm ready why I'm waiting here for you
I'll be right over
so we split after I drank the hundred we
ate three more hundred and 125 and pills
so I really had 525 in me and I went
home and function like nothing I drew my
daughter I hung out for like I watched a
movie with them that's right I watched
whatever toy story for I want the toy
story and I was losing my mind
525 milligrams 525 milligrams then do
the right thing came on and my wife goes
I'm gonna go to everything my poor
attend and that I started feeling it
they started coming on I started smoking
hash I'm smoking reefer I mean nicotine
gummies [ __ ] I will make him a protein
shake and then after the protein shake
oh [ __ ] I got those THC pills from chemo
so I was listening to Velvet Revolver
the one album and I was writing some
guys I'm sorry you know how it is you
ever start eating some popping them in
your mouth and after then you look down
yeah like four left yeah so there was
four that I had eaten like 20 of those
[ __ ] mo sleep aids yeah I'm like am I
gonna [ __ ]
shot about 30 minutes ago I feel all
right I'm not gonna die I go you know
what let me go watch narcos I still had
narcos out whatever I gonna go watch
this last episode of Marcos and I put
three key komoti days into a [ __ ] mug
and I [ __ ] drink that and that's it
oh that's it that's all I remember
I know I didn't go in I know I come bold
in there about to maybe I don't [ __ ]
know first of all after five hundred and
twenty-five milligrams I I would be I
don't even know what the [ __ ] would
happen to me if I weren't you here's the
scary thing guys do these like I'm done
with I can have to take a breather from
these oh I could definitely thought
those walk out no see I there's no one
so I could two three and nothing happens
[ __ ] all day
no had them pass out last night I passed
out like two of the [ __ ] morning but
I was [ __ ] up I got up at 7:00 7:30
yeah nothing happened
looks like nothing happened I got up a
seventh day like that happened I went in
I looked at the computer was nothing
happening and I put my sweats on and I
had but you you don't wake up high or
nothing
I had 50 for weight watcher points I
gotta hit 61 for my goal so I said [ __ ]
this I got up I drank a cup of coffee
and I will lose room to me I drink this
little red stuff like a pre energy drink
yeah on it I tracked will build that I
went right back in that bathroom
I did three [ __ ] bong hits and it's
the last one had a chunk of ass Nick the
big one
the day was on and I had my daughter dad
I'm like blown with the [ __ ] thing
out in the back bathroom I finally walk
I she said where you been like I was
back there seen say that like you know I
don't even imagine to all of the things
you told her you were doing I wasn't
back find the dress I was looking how to
speak Spanish on her own so what does a
scam there's like a program that teaches
you how to you kid how to speak Spanish
so she [ __ ] loves it she does a lot
of [ __ ] then she comes and tortures
me in Spanish book Spanish you know so
the one day we were doing it together
she got like three wrong she's like what
type is baddy to you how are you Spanish
wrong I go out understand this como come
on I don't [ __ ] know this [ __ ]
pronouns just make the [ __ ] Spanish
I'm talking alright talking that [ __ ]
back to back there you go
salud there you go don't you fight no
have no milk to them though they're like
oh [ __ ] hey coach I want leading halos
than to Mason feeling old I'm saying you
smells those dirty [ __ ] Passover
poorly I call Steve Simone Steve quale
telling me you gonna walk with you today
it's all over I can't walk no walking
that's the best time they look there's
one you know it's not 100 degrees that
you want me to go outside and walk did
you dog that's good fees what that [ __ ]
ass good for your skin yeah listen if
this is what his eyes look like right
now where's he gonna walk
his eyes must not have been open around
the way a walk you're gonna walk to get
healthy that's how to walk you don't
want to walk straight you're not gonna
do nothing straight you got a smoke to
walk you put your little iPod on and you
start walking how long and next thing
you know you and [ __ ] tell me don't
[ __ ] tell me why we're eyes [ __ ]
where is Ricky right now who knows but
don't tell me he used to walk over that
[ __ ] Hill every day no thank you
he lost like [ __ ] 80 pounds in a week
remember he was like this time they do
it home yeah yeah what makes you walk
from the valley I could be bored as [ __ ]
I'm not walking on Hollywood that's not
happening now cuz once you're in route
you're in route but dude you want your
little Canyon everywhere oh yeah I used
to walk for [ __ ] like you walk yeah
oh I told my wife dude they're like I'm
done with walking yeah she's like really
I can't do it no more I am sick of
walking I'm walking for four I'm from
New York guys I walked I walked as a kid
dude you walked here nobody [ __ ]
walks here you walked here is to walk
yeah your house to Argyle and back like
nothing cuz I used to sew screws on our
job I could walk from Vista
well I still remember us walking from
that place to the Comi storm back like
nothing my place no that [ __ ] bar we
used to Tuesday nights Union and we
didn't know if the Comedy Store was
gonna have a room I still my going
economy so getting coke walking back to
the Union
knowing you gotta walk back it's [ __ ]
July yeah it's [ __ ] hot at night is
the walk in that place had no air
conditioning no we squat to the patio
yard mm-hmm the other place had no
air-conditioning what it was packed in
there it was hot
do you [ __ ] believe that was 25 years
ago what stolen I can yeah my first
feature we can legitimately I had a
feature weekend I always tell people my
first real feature weekend was Livonia
Joey's and Detroit and
in Dearborn that was my first feature
weekend but that wasn't a club at the
time the under girl was very club my
first feature weekend was with their
Lenox in in Moscow in Moscow that
doesn't count
and then there's gotta be a club they
push you up the first one at the
underground might have been Dave oh yeah
probably Dave Fulton you might have been
yeah I think it might have been day
father I don't know man I'm neural if he
was around with that I don't know if he
was around early when we were there yes
and he around later he was around he was
coming back from England and stuff like
that he was going back and forth I think
I'm great guy yeah great comedy you know
I was it you know was it funny there to
Denver was great for me you know like
you know like when you give when you try
to open up a jar and you try and you
trying you're trying you're trying to
can open up that jar and then you give
it to your [ __ ] grandmother was 9 d
and she clicks it open that's what I
felt Seattle did for me like I was
trying too hard in Denver Seattle was
when I found that you know what I must
stick with this like Dunn was still but
did Denver the thing that I found that
was different about Seattle was you
could find longer sets when you were
starting all your sets weren't just
three or five minutes sometimes in the
early we were still doing 10 or 15 I
thank Seattle for one thing
I thank Seattle for one thing like I
went to a college yeah yeah I really am
very proud of my comedy Pat that's why
if what's so [ __ ] hard for a man you
know so it was a place where like at the
time it was a good place to be a comic
because it was a good there's a good
vibe man if people were helping each
other out good community yeah okay
what's the at alloys because of the
contest the contest is so revolved in
the Seattle Community that Monday and
Tuesday
with six minutes with a light at five
yeah
the people who aren't home or at home
you're like what's so big about that you
don't know how what it is to learn how
to be a comic finally fight for all
these years to get all this time and one
day somebody comes and goes oh by the
way we don't need you to do 25 you're
gonna do six with a line at five and if
you go over six you got a point take it
off in the contest if you do seven you
get two points taken off so you learn
why they did that
okay yeah so this is what a lot of
people don't know at home that comedy
fans about different scenes Seattle
scene was focused around the six minutes
because they wanted you to be ready for
the contest so he taught you high that
all year round no I don't give a [ __ ]
and you just did three hours in Yakima
we really don't give a [ __ ] we don't
give a [ __ ] if you did three hours of
New York here on a Monday you're gonna
do five you can have the other five and
you're gonna get off that's it yeah
whether you like it amount and Karl
would not let your eyes back on there
you ran that [ __ ] way you did 15 Carl
will even tell you at the end good set
call me again come back next Monday he
would you would not get put on that
[ __ ] stage for lack of respect Mitzi
shore now you do that for two years then
you come down here what is Mitzi shore
trained here to do three minutes yeah
that was really hard so think of the
[ __ ] why I'm so grateful that I took
the path I did yeah because if you
thought telling your life story in six
minutes is hard [ __ ] I got a level
before you tell your life story in three
[ __ ] minutes yeah so that was a
complete different animal I missed a
comedy store you know now and she said
they're not what she said
you better yeah so do you see those two
education it was two different trains of
thought I got my hostel Seattle and
Josh josh doesn't remember this I'm
Sydney chicken male one day and now
we're brothers I mean he's my brother I
love to that death but then I didn't
know Craig Gass no I didn't know Craig
guys and I'm sitting me Lobo loca one
day chomping on some chicken male on the
arm of course and Craig Gass you go do
you know crack but I go no crack opens
up with so you're the guy that's taking
everybody's work up there that's how
much work and I go yeah what's the
problem he goes man it's not fair
hey child support I'm trying to keep a
nose habit yeah knowing
I got a stripper girlfriend I got to pay
rent and I got a thousand things going
on yeah if you don't think I'm eating
your [ __ ] lunch you know and he knows
for a fact that Laura Crocker got rest
her soul did not like me but guess where
I was Tuesday Wednesday and Thursday
nights doing a free set for Laura
Crocker and at the end I got the last
laugh I would drive an hour to do a
10-minute guessing of little crackers
and I still remember the owners saying
to me how come I haven't heard of you
before and I would tell her she don't
like me but it's okay I'm just doing the
set yeah that's the mentality like I
turned of did Savage I forgot that she
didn't like you
yeah she will her got into an argument
and she told you time not to call me
guess who I called every Monday at night
ten after nine Laura Crowder amazed
Italians call I don't give a [ __ ] man a
clap I used to call she hated me and she
knew every Monday because in those days
Tuesdays yeah it was never a booking day
she knew on Tuesday night 10:00 after
9:00 I would wake up every Tuesday I
don't Laura Crocker
Joe Diaz and you would hear like yeah
and I would just I knew her schedule
wore her rooms I would have it in front
of me and I would just koala irritate
her to let her know that even though she
didn't like me I was still winning the
war yeah you might not like me but I'm
gonna do your room for free just had the
type of [ __ ] I am cuz I know at
the end of the week I'm just getting
better I'm calling up in front of 70
people I'm killing you feature whether
you got featuring once I go up there
he's lights out
the headliner don't really want me up to
him know at that time what Stano came up
there yeah and these six once I saw that
style yeah then I come to like two
months after that and I started going
off on Monday night Monday night yeah
like a different thing
once I saw staying open 96 I was like
this [ __ ] I'm doing with the suits then
why did Joey Diaz it was Mambo Kings
anomaly yeah that's how I said maracas I
used to work I worked every angle
guys you want to laugh laugh while you
are the thing I never worked the
hypnotist or odorous this is the levels
of comedy that you alright and ever
since that day me and Craig Gass became
friends like I was like Craig I'm not
here to make friends
I'm either work pay bills and get better
as a comic and that changed and then we
became great friends ya know then we
came back Lionel Lionel Lionel
there was a Picasso you gotta remember
this you know dude he's on Facebook no
he's not a hundred percent
don't tell me his last name afterward
that's the one I had come up that was
you know I don't know what people think
comedy clubs are but for most people I'm
gonna spread the word they're not a
church and they'll never ever be a
sanctuary
let's not even talk about the Comedy
Store that's not even talking about the
club where I came up in Denver let's
talk about
be underground for a second okay
at this time and this is my witness I
still remember going to the underground
had a quarter late cuz that's what you
did on Monday nights you got there the
quarter day you already signed up once
you got seniority
Carl signed job but we would go to
correlate how many nights did you walk
in there and the 8 o'clock Billy was
already doing blow the bar oh come on
he used that false teeth and his teeth
would rattle and he would show them to
you he would shortly dog you can't write
this [ __ ] but his laugh you could hear
his laugh this I pitched it was crazy
but how hot was his girlfriend crazy
asian lazy heart you know how many mics
I saw her at 7:30 watch come on what's
the other guy that's on Facebook they
used to work on Saturdays a dub club
with the white hand another [ __ ]
great guy that lives in Ireland now
close to Fulton with the white hair
white hair back then with little hippy
glasses how good were these guys yes I
remember sitting there with him one
night young bro look at the waitress she
was nod Billy was high on coke
she was high on heroin two of the other
waitresses while I am heroin hair always
big up there that's what [ __ ] Alice
this is within ninety five guys I still
never going to giggles and the hottest
waitress and giggles was a hippie chick
and I said I like pills from her we know
whatever coke and I stole my mother
saying to me wouldn't gonna go up to
Lance what was the singer Alice in
Chains weights daily is that his name is
that his name he's dead
I don't know how many times she said to
me what the lanes house or whatever we
did do some smack they were all go on a
cab well that
girl was beautiful she had to be if it
was 95 I was dirty too
she had to be 23 24 I don't know how
many times she sold me drugs
when standing laying stay I'm nice I
don't know how many times she told me on
Saturday night see blood yeah needles I
would have gone up there if who was a
cocaine party I'm not gonna lie to you I
would have gone up there you wouldn't
think this was cocaine I would have
still been at Wayne State I wasn't
stupid Elaine Staley sighs that plane
Stanley yeah
that's down in the hole you ain't leavin
you ain't leavin you're just gonna die
in his living room but she didn't say
nothin bout blow I think she would get
me blow but she would always say to me
yeah but you know Mike I'm not doing no
[ __ ] shot that was giggles in the
youth district yeah that was like we had
barely barely I didn't mess man I never
liked I never felt good method because
Laura did mess room there was something
with Laura and underground yeah Fox
so since Laura was your manager but he
also this dude what was his name the
owner of the gig yeah when we first got
there the owner of giggles was a pilot
in Vietnam and he had been shot down he
was [ __ ] nuts he had a Jaguar he
drove a black Jaguar was it that he
pulled up Don remember he pulled up on
the side if you want stage you could see
him pull up and you knew you had to go
pg-13 before that you have up there
eatin ass but it's very walk through the
back of the showroom and I have to go to
knock-knock jokes
like one animal won't you play cards
with a cheetah
and once he would leave that thing I'd
start all over again what's up my dick
you [ __ ] new district [ __ ]
so what was the track coach from
Washington State nicest guy in the world
funniest [ __ ]
he plays flappers and every time he's a
flat but I want to go over and say hello
Dolman hug him he was the guy with the
glasses from Seattle he was a professor
[ __ ] funny [ __ ] he performs
down here yes he comes down once he and
does flappers he's on stage one night is
he this [ __ ] I think was on that
night yeah okay and he's a funny [ __ ]
dude and he's spotless clean let me tell
you how [ __ ] crazy of the yellow was
I'm up on stage talking about farting
people faces whatever he's up there
talking about Disneyland at the end were
both sitting at the bar and the owner
walks up to him and says let me tell you
something
when I went through the show hours
buddies with a couple of wages up there
they all started coke - giggles girls I
used to get the coke from their waitress
ed the ending all those waitresses but
the girl in giggles used to get me coke
especially so I had it down let me tell
how down I had giggles Thursday night
was that [ __ ] room he had he had a [ __ ]
room Olympia Oh
Olimpia all about when I will help you
follow chair Olympia seeded Olympia on
Thursday he did something else there on
Thursdays so my goal was always to leave
a leave Olympia you could drive with the
headliner [ __ ] you
I would leave Olympia well while the
headliner was on stage and I chewed up
to giggles and I'd catch him hey weren't
you in Olympia yeah let me get her on
your advance already can't you can't
this wait till Saturday listen I have
time the wait till Saturday I buy the
water bill give me a hundred bucks will
you he would give me a hundred he was
such a Vietnam vet tell her sadly to pay
me the full amount so I started telling
everybody yo good man on Thursdays don't
wait
co-op they hit him up for the hundred
he's [ __ ] Vietnam vets were gone
like you know they've God you know so
this one are not like everybody I told
like you have no idea I don't even Gavin
did it that was why this guy Gavin
wouldn't rob anybody but a hundred bucks
yeah that was a hundred bucks I was
telling ya every feature was I dog
you're right he doesn't remember that a
Mormon guy bought it he was like yeah
yeah Terry Terry you're not working yeah
yeah I didn't know the first guy Terry
Terry that club was cool guys we were a
family nobody [ __ ] nobody nobody got
that big something that that club was a
drug college club who is that I was
right in the you district of Seattle
mm-hmm and I would love working there
because salaries I would get great coke
uptown but there was two what three wait
to fizzle was solid damn the heroin
check then there was a white chick and I
would tell her fried Apes the man who's
featured next week she'd go nobody I
would work Thursday Olympia Friday at
the club salad club I'd have contact
with him both nights
you know I'd call him Monday at nine
o'clock and go yo Jody is he good how
you doing Joey I know who's your feature
this week and he go
when was the last time you feature at
the club I go last year he goes all
right you got the job next week that's
how crazy that guy Wallace that he would
just see me I just worked with him
Friday and Saturday I would call him
Monday and I would ask him when I could
feature the last time you featured at
the club like the last year and then I
got Gavin on it so it was there was a
point where I would be there for two
weeks
Gavin would be there for two weeks I
would be there for two weeks it was like
stealing it was like the perfect [ __ ]
timely dream up there we were just kids
yeah I can't believe I never you know
last night I told you two nights ago I'm
watching fourth of July night the night
I got [ __ ] stoned
yeah that's one of the one of things cuz
I remember the end of 11:00 I watch do
the right thing I went to get up to go
piss last night and it was when she and
Carlo what's the dude Derby thinks is
good from Breaking Bad a black dude with
a little circular glass yeah Giancarlo
whatever is having a talk with radio
Raheem and they're talking about over
throwing saps that we need to boycott
Sal's famous and it goes yeah that
[ __ ] yelled at me for having my
stereo on didn't even say please he goes
we've spent mucho month he goes we spend
mucho dollars in there and then got no
pictures of brothers on the wall he goes
they just kind of much look tough
Sylvester Stallone looking [ __ ]
up a wall I was standing up guys
last night I was walking up into the
living room to go to use the house
bathroom instead of mine I was gonna pee
in there cuz I thought I had his [ __ ]
when he said he has a bunch of Sylvester
Stallone with him [ __ ] up there
he needs to put some brothers up on the
wall my knee buckled because it was the
first time I had thought about Brody in
a long time me Josh
Brody like six of us are down in Gig
Harbor Washington on Saturday night and
we're like eat in the bag and dick
we don't know who's headlining we would
just show up like if you hired me and
Josh yeah but you only you're supposed
to do 45 yes we got it will they just do
10 apiece yeah what the [ __ ] is going on
like it was crazy and I still remember
going to Gig Harbor when I told him we
put him in the back drunk I told them
cuz he pissed me off don't [ __ ] tell
me you can't make it the gig harbin an
hour and a half and he kept arguing meto
[ __ ] down me well I tell you I could
do something I could do it I'm not
telling you cuz I mind here he kept
telling me couldn't drive from Seattle
gig harbor huh and then I'm like are you
[ __ ] crazy because it takes me like
three hours got rest is slow Brody Steve
he's arguing me one night I'm like Brody
we're leaving here [ __ ] six o'clock
I'm not getting on don't take you know
five and three hours he had a Volvo
station wagon dude he's not Jesse then
we put him in the kids seat in the back
you know how the back opens up I took
him by the throat I go get that [ __ ]
back shut the [ __ ] up I'm gonna show you
how to get a gig harbor and I wanna have
and we would do a 90 and there wasn't
even an HOV we had an old [ __ ] up man
we look at me remembers and Brody
Stevens kept yelling stop slow down
normal people don't live like this I'm
like I'm not normal [ __ ] people I'm
not normal
and I still living at me there and going
up on stage oh he was mad he had older
gig harbor had thousands of pictures of
people up on the wall why black Spanish
Vince Valenzuela yes all these famous
comics up there but I don't know what
happened Brody's furious he's doing his
set in the middle of all this he looks
up at the wall and he goes where's the
[ __ ] owner any other second I'm the
owner he goes you better put some
[ __ ] Jews up on oh my god we lost in
the back I'm not coming here [ __ ]
again do you put some Jews up on that
wall this is gig hall but I haven't seen
a Jew
since [ __ ] depression this is too
dark it reminds us of washed which
there's no Jew in Seattle there's not a
temple in Seattle to remind him too much
of March which if there's no sunlight
there's no sunlight you don't see Jews
visiting Seattle [ __ ] you or Buffalo boy
oh my god he kept when he got out of the
car in the parking lot he was still
yelling at land the door and he said I
do not live my life this way he was so
[ __ ] mad and he was in the back
making those [ __ ] weird yeah
I was I was getting this close to cause
I'm holding my fingers just to [ __ ] with
him I would get real close to the car
stop at this cause of my mother's name
oh god that was really funny oh my god
then he had a cable-access show and he
had a pager pager number
he's thinking he's on the [ __ ] Carol
Burnett Show Brodie God rest his soul
and I'm a Gavin just [ __ ] him down his
pager and he's dying to pick it up
he's legs shake him he's dying like I'm
leaving messages and finally running a
TV show
holy [ __ ] that's well Carly's about
ladies and gentlemen okay 25 [ __ ]
years like just a story we walk that dog
like they was walking I'm doing coke on
the walk and tell about my mother
finding my mother on the war he's like I
never knew that about you you would get
ready to leave this is 96 verse 96 yeah
like you will believe in the following
week I had to move out of his house I
lived in his back house that was a great
setup by the way it was a great set that
was a great set this was a great house
we were hidden what you pay for that
house maybe eleven hundred and something
like that we
gigantic yeah please [ __ ] gigantic
huge it was but do you remember remember
when she where she was putting the
garbage she was putting it in the garage
and she wasn't taking it out and so we
had these mounds this mound of garbage
in the garage and I said I called the
exterminator and I was like hey and I
didn't know this I know hey man so I
think we have some critters but you take
a look into the house and he goes yeah
and he got mmm maybe his head in and he
turned around he goes I go what's wrong
you guys there's a lot of eyes looking
back at me I go what in under the house
and he goes there's got to be a food
source somewhere around here I'm like a
food source like what the [ __ ]
and he goes let's go check the garage
and I opened the garage and she'd just
been taking the trash out to the garage
so he was like here's the food source I
was like get the [ __ ] cuz we had that
circular driveway so we never used her
I'd love for the death the best but till
this day she is the filthiest woman
she's the reason why I won't eat Thai
food no that's not right I swear to God
cuz she still not wash dishes and the
fruit flies oh yeah why is in the
kitchen every day so she was tired so I
held that against her like you're
[ __ ] you don't wash your dishes I
mean one person is a reason why oh
that's all I need they sent me the wrong
representative you know I'm saying if
you gonna send me the representative
send me the right tie dude
I loved her she was my sister yeah I
loved it but when it came to that [ __ ]
she drove me crazy
she wouldn't have him one time you left
like a month I don't wash dishes and
water was like quickly like the kids
wanted something to drink it was like
sticking your hand and quickcam I think
thing was gonna grab you that's how
murky cuz she would soak the
she's and not washing and I'm like how
do I get a glass and I'm like here goes
you gotta like close your eyes and stick
your hand the [ __ ] water
I still remember Vista with the fruit
flies and you used to bit don't make
believe you know I remember the front we
used to do that you know it was great
dude and what I loved you would do it
just for you I don't know where you just
go it used to make me laugh
no matter where we were you go our story
that we can now we can't even go into
about how funny by the way she she was a
legitimately funny birth took me maybe
five years I still yearned there's not
too many people in your life you can
meet that when they touch your hand and
say come with me you're gonna see an
adventure I think I want to over with
her three nights and I saw all I had to
say if she was she I have a friend Mike
Batali he should be married to my sister
when you went out with him you don't
know what you gonna see be prepared and
don't be in shock
she was that much fun she just was a
responsible that was the whole thing fun
was her number one priority getting high
all that stuff going to work fiber
Malaysia she was the first person I ever
they get five in Malaysia I will tell
you this that Lane was Malia so we used
to call it five of Malia right to her
face like what's going on with you was I
can I will I believe I will tell you
this though she I love what a judge she
could Riley she could get in late dude
and if the alarm went off she would be
like tell me when I got 10 minutes ain't
nothing like he got 10 minutes and she
really liked bing-bang-boom and she'd be
out the [ __ ] door and I mean I got it
she
could get up and get to work we didn't
[ __ ] around now had no choice in those
days yes more cookie you gotta pay the
piper
you wanna snort coke you gotta pay the
piper once you accept it that you can
live off an hour's sleep till nights you
do it yeah you do it you know I just
there's a radio show I listen to on
Sunday nights it's it's nothing for you
guys you guys just would not like it I
like it because it's only good once a
month its studio 54 radio yeah I get in
the car do you get Sunday nights a
damira
myra doesn't mind caste bro once a month
she gets a guest that'll blow your socks
off like like a real legit not like the
door guys when they start talking about
amazing and all that [ __ ] nah once in a
while once a month they get a guest
that's like a dentist like the most
famous what I heard was his dentist and
his wife came on Teleca hundred now and
they were talking about going to studio
54 and what their lifestyle was like
they went six nights a week and they had
kids but there was Long Island so the
kids you know your mother lives in the
house but yeah so your parents live on
the first floor and you live on the
second floor so they told the story six
nights a week can you imagine going on
six nights a week you and your wife and
leaving two kids at the house six nights
a week and he was a dentist what saved
them was they were both dentist and they
owned the dentist thing together yeah
and they just lay the story on you that
you could not believe of they would wake
up at they would get home at 7:00 sleep
till 10:00
put the kids to school then come back
sleep from 8:00 to 11:00 get up go to
the dentist shop be a dentist till 3:00
go home take another nap pick the kids
up from school help them with their
homework take them to all their events
go home put them in the shower and at
nine o'clock they take a nap till eleven
o'clock eleven o'clock they get up get
dressed get the [ __ ]
midnight they'd be at Studio 54 so 6:00
in the morning and they do that six
nights a [ __ ] week you sit there and
go how the [ __ ] does this happen
Malia could do that there's people who
could do that yeah there's people I did
it I did it from 83 the God knows yeah I
was yeah listen you want snort coke
that's fine but no you gotta get up for
a plane at 5:00 yeah you gotta make the
plane or you got to make the car you
know many times I woke up in that Moscow
Idaho and the room was spinning and the
only thing get me going with that last
blast of coke you have in the morning so
you brush your teeth and do that one
blast of coke that's a heart attack for
most people but just to straighten up to
drive home from Moscow either that drive
home was terror that was five and a half
hours but always hungover
always hello yeah yeah it's just just
[ __ ] pure Crazy's before we wrap up I
gotta ask you one thing
mm-hmm well the funniest things ever
because nobody's really talked about
this lately at all everybody's talking
about this and I don't think it was it
really nobody has the reason to talk
about it doesn't matter to a lot of
people but you haven't said bhumata
Tom Brady what the [ __ ] just happened
guys did we miss it because the corona
virus is Cam Newton now the new face
yeah
Oh what don't clap please good now
they'll be all 1:19 Oh is he a mush Oh
looking for vetting not for everyone for
everything House Rules everything every
six rules whatever and you didn't bet
one of them that's right he's a mutant
bet 100 you could give him a lock call
you an hour and say it
he moisturize yeah I got two little
locks I'm working on it for this weekend
of the NFC and I won't even let him know
do you ever just ask him who you like
and they just pick some but the other
person all dog if he gets up I know it
I'm saying like if he wakes up it's
gonna be a bad [ __ ] day
I gave him blocks already come on he'll
put him in a parlay or three times
teasers or something I give my wife this
bet this I put in a parlay I gave him a
yard one time and I'm up he left he left
he lost again you leave when you're up
then he became a professional gambler
that was disaster day they actually he's
the only guy got thrown out of the South
Point what he's banned for life how did
you get thrown out of South Point it's
cuz his bunny showed up passing out
edibles like there was Willy Wonka here
it was a person took more than a
thousand milligrams of the stars his the
other guy used to make the stars was
literally pouring them in my hands I
gotta give him a one charge guy [ __ ]
the Navy SEAL rejected was sitting there
staring at me
wait being a security guard wait you
seriously okay
here the bulletproof vest and he said
war honor that we have you on tape
little did he know that I ate the rest
of them and he walked up to my room and
wouldn't let me add you leave the hotel
I couldn't go to Vegas and check in with
the police and let them know that when I
get to Vegas by law first my first stop
is you gotta check in with the police
department for real yeah what did you
where did you go oh you think he went
you think he wasn't way like deemed up
being dal-rae you give Dean Delroy 20
bucks at 9:30 at night in Vegas
yesterday at the Palacio
he'll get a suite something for 20 bucks
I don't know how Dean does you ever seen
being in action now in New York
Dean would stay out all night to about
ten till the hotel drops their prices on
a nap and they let you go in there for
like $12.99 - come on bro you have no
idea these [ __ ] young [ __ ]
got [ __ ] up their sleeve
you deem that way would do spots and
carriers close to spots and then get
like a hotel 11 like the Park Avenue
rich 4995 what's it called what's the
[ __ ] hotels tonight you're not gonna get
it like 3:00 in the afternoon right
you're gonna get like 12 11 and probably
in every city there's a room yes
somewhere there's a rule somewhat deemed
oh it has met you don't know how many
times he's called me like from [ __ ]
the hotel there's horses in front of it
you [ __ ] people get the horse carriages
overlooking Central Park I'm like would
you pay for that hotel $89 it was a
steal and it came with breakfast I'm
doing my laundry this is great I'm like
what got like a [ __ ] suite for $89
I'm gonna give that a run yeah he's got
like yeah
what the [ __ ] if your comic that's what
you know yeah I mean if I specially cuz
I can fly in late go straight to the
club yeah that way I don't to get up
early
yeah that's actually not a terrible idea
Oh Dean down right came into the other I
got them fish he won't eat fish she goes
where do I get fish in the valley he was
I'm up here I gotta meet you I'm in the
same move for the same fish let's go up
to big Tony so with our cold water on
Fridays they got great salmon something
tremendous Mexican salmon said well I'll
meet you up a big tall he's only
cheating there so we just took up to go
and we sat here and ate and talked [ __ ]
like alright so wait you going back to
where you live no I live down the block
for meal he just moved to Studio City he
scored a two-bedroom two-bath price
Corona price he's been watching there
for a year good for him man they went
food you don't even want to know I
missed a drop and he worked he beat me
he told me yes we told me
Sunday said man no one that I gave it to
me for this price I just saw two people
moving out cuz this place is empty and
all go up to victory and Lankershim and
look at the u-haul place there ain't no
[ __ ] you can't even find the [ __ ]
cart go-kart you can't push a go-kart
there people go carting out of here I'd
go up there go see how many moving
trucks did you see I see a four-day and
then that one neighborhood yeah it's bad
people you can't afford to live here
ain't no no that's you know the new
rumor is people in the industry again
the [ __ ] out of here that going close to
North Carolina in Atlanta because
believe it on that homeboy Tyler Perry
his systems been working his system is
the only system that's been working yeah
all these other TV shows I've had to
cancel they can't figure out
check your sag emails from now on check
out my they go into your junkie man yeah
start reading you really die they
canceling [ __ ] every day
[ __ ] starting on Monday this shuts down
by one second shuts down can't even keep
a low so the move to North Carroll
staying all our studio is saying that
this ain't gonna work here it's just not
gonna work it's just not gonna work just
not gonna work
it's too restrictive and too expensive
but Tyler Perry's paying all the loot to
solid Perry's paying you for 30 days
yeah
it's costing you 30 days work yeah it's
16 days before the shoot is your first
cold good test you're on the clock and
they pay you for that right then at the
plane at Van Nuys Airport you get tested
again when you land you get tested again
then you get put in seclusion you get
tested again then you get put into an
area and you stay in that area
you know you shoot and you just hang
with those people who are actors and
first team and even that gets cut into
three so you really have access to like
six people unless you go to the set you
get tested every other day so you get
tested Monday Wednesday and Friday and I
guess make up everybody and everybody's
staying in a hotel everybody stay in a
bubble but like right but like where is
everyone sleeping everybody standing
like a hotel slash studio got and it
they built like walls in there like
there's a mall you go to everything you
need is there
you know how to leave two weeks Jesus no
leaving that's why I don't know what's
gonna happen like so you're telling me
Xeon William isn't the Rookie of the
Year is not gonna get his dick sucked
well you try to tell me NBA players are
gonna stay in a bubble from July from
next week till the channel is the
championship in November that's you're
trying to tell me they're gonna stay in
a bubble good luck good luck that's
never gonna happen
I don't think there's any chance
everybody stays in the bubble we were
raised to sneak out at night yet we're
raised to put a dummy in the bed I'll
paint a good I'm saying I'll put a tape
recorder I'll just take myself coughing
and just play it every 20 minutes the
thing goes oh he's in there yeah we got
the ropes my favorite move of yours of
all time by the way because I had never
seen it before and you can't do it
anymore but I did it a couple times
myself when times were rough there was
going into the department store picking
up a couple of comforters walking up to
the counter and saying I'd like to
return these and they'd be like great
and you like we can't give you cash
without like store credit and you were
like fine
I was always my absolute I was like wait
and they just give it to you in there
you're like yeah then we give me cash
because you don't have a receipt from
that that was my open mic er that was
the hustle you know everybody has like
you got a developmental deal that was my
developmental deal was I just figured
out when I left New York in October at
93 and I went to back to bold I'm like
how am I gonna making a living
I could sell cars but the debt I was in
was so overwhelming the debt was just
coming in by the thousands an attorney
I'm having attorney on the fly you drop
the four old [ __ ] week I would drop
off two and the guys like oh by the way
here's your next bill you know copies
whatever [ __ ] he would charge me for
everything wrong cause were 250 a phone
call you know I mean it was a nightmare
so I couldn't make a [ __ ] living so
everything I made got taken from me I
don't even know how I I think I was
somewhere one day I brought something
and I returned two things and I'm like
come on
and it was the old Boulder mall they had
a made DNS that I would go there pick up
$249 comforters yeah that the cover was
the move bring them back what do you and
then I figured out oh [ __ ] what did the
places that gave you checks if people or
store credit I avoid them unless I
needed a suit or something then I took
the store credit but there were people
who just trade up gave you cash and I
gotta be honest here I got you want me
to lie to I get lighty from 93 October
to June of 95 and even farther than that
because I was doing it on the road I was
doing on Tribble I got quite a long time
and I don't wanna zoom look returning
some returning something oh yeah they
let me go but I [ __ ] made a stink
minority [ __ ] OJ Simpson
I'm like out of all the places that
figured me out I know somebody who's
just watching you they squat me from the
beginning so as I went in and took it
they will watch me I know I was like a
brother more spaghetti you throw against
the wall yeah it's gonna stay yeah so I
was getting cocky like I was walking
into a place at 9:30 ah wrong move
you're gonna get nailed there's nobody
in the store you gotta wait to this on
your people miss Darlene you walk in
name just mix right in but I still let
me tell how [ __ ] desperate I was
because I don't there's no reason we
like there was a time to pay rent like
read week I would just hang outside
there was a payphone and Kmart and
Boulder and having just make-believe I
was paying off and I would watch people
hallway receipts you know what an
ambulance chaser is mm-hmm
I was an ambulance chaser thief receipt
so people that come out of the stores
throw away the receipt four out of ten
people yeah I mean a couple white people
take home their receipts let me you
couldn't get your [ __ ] luggage back
yeah nobody saves their receipts yeah
how many times I stood there and saw
people come out that is what I do they
were rotating something unless you draw
away the receipt and I pick up the
receipt now I got you now I got you I'd
walk in like [ __ ] whistle why you is
a jerk you know I just walk in now pick
up the thing and [ __ ] walk up to the
counter with the receipt how you doing
I don't want this you just bought it ten
minutes ago yeah I just don't want you
just bought this you have no [ __ ]
idea
Kmart was the spot and Kmart knew I was
robbing them and Boulder I lived right
across the street from me so does Mike
the go spot so when came I would get too
hot then I would start going in the mall
it was like made D&F RadioShack I put
them
to business I've been going into a Radio
Shack and Boulder in 85
they had a CD player on the wall and I
looked around the cellar and wouldn't
talk to me I was like [ __ ] I just
couldn't walk you have no idea you have
no I wish I was lined when I walk that
lap mall I'm like my friends at
homeowners I just unplugged it and we're
playing like Superman or something
I am plug then I took the vows I just
walked out with the whole [ __ ]
apparatus that's what we crazy like I'm
like I got Rogan going to me because I
drove into Bolden I could tell this
place is like one huge candy store it
became one huge candy couldn't figure me
out I'm not proud of these things that's
why what a boulder because I told Lee
disrespected Boulder like Thole like
just I turned the lab I know what my
rent wasn't bold four hundred you know I
paid my rent September of 94 hmm I was
waiting outside of the came one of the
phone it was renting it was the 31st of
[ __ ] August guys and I'm like I've
been waiting on deaf like an hour and a
half nobody's trying to recede away I
was just about ready to hang my hat down
and get the [ __ ] out of there cuz then I
had i sat plants like plan a is Kmart
Plan B as I robbed this guy that's a big
jump man oh this is a good one if you
could smell the fart with a mask on you
did a good job you don't say Doug I
still remember needing four hundred for
the red this is unbelievable and I'm
laying there by the payphone it was like
three payphones that was the same pay
phone I used my turn myself it I knew it
the ins and outs it was across the
street from a Coco's restaurant in front
of an Albertsons I knew the whole layout
it six years earlier
I was on that same pay phone torturing
the cops because they couldn't put a
trace around me so I can call on the
capital and I want to talk to the
detective Josh wolf and they're like
who's calling I'm like Jose Diaz I call
that click I'd hang up where's Josh wolf
who's this Joe Diaz don't put me at home
gonna have to put you on hold
clicked don't hang up I would keep
hanging up on and then farther they go
Joe Diaz hold on we'll put you on with
detective Cola and he's like where are
you I'm gonna forget this being on the
phone in my Kmart and looking at Coco's
and Albertsons and gone I'm at the
Albertson's on 28th Street if you want
to talk to music we'll be right there
just two of us promise we'll be right
there
I remember hanging up the phone and
walking to my car and taking a newspaper
we're all enjoying and watching the
Albertsons and watching cop cars pull up
from all [ __ ] directions and they're
running in with their guns at the
opportune to be going oh I'm in trouble
oh my god I'm in [ __ ] trouble I have
gone into town to get Lethal Weapon and
above the law at the video store and I
go you know what my buddy George I met
him and I had to came on he goes the
cops are looking for you they came by
the dealership he left his card if you
want to call call this guy I thought
about it I should call and see what it
was but that was the exact same pay
phone where I call the cops one was
toying with them I'm like I'll be at the
Albertson's I'll see you there wait wait
wait what are you driving with the
minutes I just saw cops pulling up from
all directions into the Albertson's
running in so I need four miles to pay
the rent I'm standing on that pay phone
I'm staring up that Koko's and guess
what I see some [ __ ] redneck II
looking guy pushing the hang carts
yeah and he's pushing now I'm Longmore
one of those ones that you sit on yeah
and Osun he just saw a receipt fly up in
the air was like God ha ha ha
[ __ ] heavenly justice it just
flew out from under the day I thought
the guy was gonna see it I took the guy
that bought it was gonna see it nobody
saw nothing I took the lady because all
those white people in Boulder you know
you litter no [ __ ] have a cow pick
that up please
there was a couple of women nobody said
nothing it was my lottery ticket and I
went over and I picked it up ooh
tremendous I love it throw some to leave
Lee wants him give some coaching Lee
there you go so I go over I picked this
[ __ ] receipt up guess how much it was
before I don't have any idea 400 [ __ ]
pounds of my rent it was perfect it was
four hundred and something dollars I'm
like I made [ __ ] rent by going to
Kmart they're sold out of those lowboys
in the [ __ ] you think that's not me
[ __ ] no I got in that car did 90 the
wrong month there was another came on a
long month no internet no nothing I just
knew there was one a long month I went
all the way the long month got that 20
minutes later walked in walked into the
green or the garden department we have
all the trees and there was three of
them I'd like three dollars in my pocket
I got one of the guys go come here for a
second load that up for me please is
three dollars those days three dollars
was like a ten yeah the guy picked up a
lot more I Hercules put it on and he
good do you what to pay for this like oh
yeah push it over to the thing he
actually pushed up to the counter I gave
the lady receipt in front of him he's
like look at him I go and leg gives me
back 400 plus tax
excuse me like for 40 I'm like what what
I got lunch I got my rent money that's
how deep and dirty I was yeah like I was
just chasing receipts some people
ambulance chasers I would just sit there
and chase receipts and
then the [ __ ] coffee craze started
the expresso yeah but Mochaccino machine
and the coffee there were four fifty
apiece
I was clipping three of those a day and
I would go to different locations in
there all day no oh please wait to come
[ __ ] I had different Aurora I had
all the towns where they did the
shooting at the movie theater yeah
I know exactly what that movie did it
was that Moore was down the corner when
that movie theater I used to go there
all the time so I read that at different
itineraries Monday would be Boulder if I
was desperate but Sunday I would really
go out Sunday and Saturday my big days
at coverage there my big money
disharmony I got so high one night I
went to the county works I just started
calmly been doing comedy for two years
but I wasn't in with them yet
so I what to see Jackie Flynn uh-huh and
I took a date and made me pay I had 18
of hours in my pocket from stealing that
day I was so high I took the money out
paid him that put a penile on the
counter walked away and when I got the
drinks I went back to get the money and
an 1800 was missing and nobody knew
where it was the girl I was with how to
pay for the drink said I'll pay in the
morning
I just went robbed another 18 it was
just for machines it was for machines
cuz you would get for 50 plus tax you
didn't like 500 bucks that's crazy
so I read and would go to a different
look that was my open mic that's what I
did as an open mic that's how I finally
it's my life is an open micro that
wholesome was just bringing [ __ ] back
every big Toys R Us oh I made a mockery
out of that baby cash no they give you
every money Oh Geoffrey I went in there
one day and brought back a computer and
left there with a bicycle
Christmas in 94 everything my daughter
got was on one run and I mean everything
computer bicycle Barnes dollhouses
I was going in just I would start with
like a little thing it's done you know
these are just things that happen this
is how you put put it together when
you're coming this is how the only way I
knew how I wasn't gonna get no [ __ ]
job there's no way I was getting a job
when I was two years in I had already
done all that [ __ ] my 94 there was no
where I tried to get a job I would get
jobs at different car lights just for
the advance I would tell him I could
speak Spanish I could sell 15 cars a
month call anybody in town but I need a
car
I need a nickel up front then give me a
car that's how I go to the gigs
Judy Brown I still remember gonna want a
Judy Brown's gays in the car blew up and
I just left it there
I just took like a bus into town and
left the car the dealership call me
three days later where's that car what
the [ __ ] is it doing up in the bail row
I was killing dealerships killing
dealership killing dealerships there's a
guy that's still my friend that lives in
Pismo Beach and we had got into a
conversation about this about a year ago
because when you worked for me at that
juice store you were a nightmare what
the [ __ ] were you doing I was just
taking the car and that like whatever I
wanted I would just take a new car and
then I went to work for used car dealers
after the new cars would hire me no more
slumping mica cuz I could speak Spanish
so they had a public I go in there and
put them together listen do me a favor
give me 15 up front to give me a car and
I skip a sinkhole so people will come
down there look at me Telemundo I'd have
elastic I never lasted I never I quit
all the time I quit every [ __ ] job oh
wait I would just go take the job just
to have it then one day I took a
for a used car dealership I knew the
girl I had had an affair with the girl
and she called me up when this is like
Joey these guys don't pay anything to
come work up here they looking for a
Spanish guy that was my last car job
business I go her name is Lori I go put
them together get me 2,500
you gotta work ding - ding that means
all day four days straight then two days
off or whatever I got right I went there
they gonna pick a car the first [ __ ]
car that's what I was Bush see he
doesn't understand like a column whoosh
cuz I used to be mush
at that time yeah everything I touch
turns to [ __ ]
every car everything I touched whenever
I touch blew up if I bet bro if I bet a
team even if the other team didn't show
up I'd find it was terrible I know mush
I know moist as I live mush so I had to
I had a gig in like [ __ ] Wyoming you
can't write this [ __ ] that's like full
of snow coming down so I didn't want the
snow to settle so I left after the gig
at this time I'm doing 3540 what car did
you take one of that cause I'm off to
use Carla yeah I'm picking Greeley and a
Haley something's wrong with the car I'm
like man this is getting hot in this car
and all of a sudden I'm smelling like
fire I'm like come on
and sure enough I pull over bro and
something was on fire on the hood I just
took my suitcase and within 10 minutes
I hit like boom and you can see like the
flames in the car I just walked away
from it that's the second time I had my
life good car I was driving
just lit in flames you know people think
like I call him here I lived it
tell him about the car I had in Seattle
tell him about the car no yeah the car I
had in Seattle when I first moved to
Seattle the last month I had that car I
was driving it without not a bumper but
what's the side panel the that covered
the wheels yeah yeah without it was all
that was my eye yeah I made 800 miles
flat car that was the best car I've ever
had in my life why do I know because I
put that car through commando tactics I
drove from Denver to Baltimore in that
car easy 15 times do you still drive the
way you used to drive yes what do you
mean just like you beaten Lee used to
beat the [ __ ] out of your cars yes and
no I'm a horrible person Allah cause
because and that's why I don't buy a
Cadillac yeah
that's why that's why I won't buy a BMW
because I've lived cars on fire nobody
but nobody has had worse luck with cars
tell uncle Joey I was the original mush
I still don't be an eighteen and
delivering electronical parts and [ __ ]
company and I went somewhere while I
wasn't supposed to be and the guy would
always send me my cometh always takes
you longer than everybody else and I
always have some a story do you know
that one day in 1983 in the snow and
Jersey I was making a delivery for this
[ __ ] guy this could only happen to me
this electrical poles and there's like
little wires on the bottom yeah this is
the pole and there's usually like these
steel beams one day I was going in
Reverse in the snow and the back of the
wheel well caught that beam and I'm up
there
gorilla guys I'm not built for that [ __ ]
out the car and I go look I'm like [ __ ]
this I'm like how can this happen to me
and at that time that was like a yeah
like a thing like a CB he's like did
these ideas beers come in come in where
are you I'll be right there look at this
thing it's on 89th Street North Bergen
it's like a side street behind I used to
live in that rocket ship in that Park it
was right there it was on the corner
there and I went to visit a friend and I
went up that hill for some [ __ ]
reason and something happened I went to
backup and I got caught on that thing
and you know me I'm like how am I gonna
get out of this I got the car I'm like
[ __ ] drive to like in those days that
drive to drive one I had that
[ __ ] - oh my god
and it's all sudden I'm like [ __ ] so
how'd it go across the street I took the
bucket and I got sand from the
playground yeah and this how crazy I was
like I pushed the [ __ ] snow
I got Sam from the plague walking back
the cars the one and you get Diaz Diaz
Hamid you know where you were must you
remember when we were catering and you
lit those trash cans around clearly
- man I'm steppin on this thing haha oh
my car and the car lost I'm looking
behind there's like little flames coming
out of the tires like spark and
obviously you see the thing started the
metal started moving in the electrical
pole started going back and forth I'm
like this [ __ ] put like d1 oh my
god the thing is gonna fall it's got a
424 dog I drove so hard the back of the
van came off I just said [ __ ] you I'm
coming back I pull up like Matheny's out
they wait for me with who delivery -
black enough Ana's God I'm wide open I'm
freezing to death cuz there's no doors
it just took that whole piece off with
the bumper and the tie a dick the whole
thing came off I'm gonna fall off but
he's a little Arab game isn't it what
the [ __ ] was his name and we used to
torture him he's still there God he's
still there Boulevard hog well he's
still there George something and he was
Arab and we used to hand him the kid who
got me the job there the father worked
there buh bah bah boom boom Bob look
something like that and the other sister
was a half freak and his name was joy
son his name was George me lad
so Easter call me George me God in the
Bahamas couple times I bring him coke
and he go crazy you run the place with
me I think I lasted three months there
and even with the torn van you know I
got that's I took my first pinch when I
was working at Boulevard where he didn't
fire after the van no I blame though you
don't meet though I could talk anybody
into anything I talked them in Tyler
what are you talking about
the back of the van where is it like I
said that was my favorite van
yeah you told me gonna know when did you
go to Newark um I glanced make remember
I never what the Newark in that [ __ ]
thing having to be number from the whole
back of the van my god I went back there
that night I just took the back me and
my buddies I took it pushed onto the
people's property like two people they
must have flipped when they woke up and
sit on the back of the van it was one of
those vans like that you [ __ ] actually
rape people in the back you mean he was
a Windows and yeah he was a filthy
[ __ ] sack nobody was customized Oh
like it was like an extra van he had cuz
he was so busy with deliveries
delivering wood nails and all this [ __ ]
so he's like you gonna have to drive
that van so I used to [ __ ] steal [ __ ]
from him like when I had brought a piece
to have those Makita drug drills
Makena saws [ __ ] and I would steal them
every delivery like he would go stock
this job so I would take a piece of
paper down and there'd be like a pallet
and if it called fit through to Makino's
I put six on that and I would take him
right to my little junkie buddy bonehead
and he'd buy them from me give me kick
come by the house laying out that gay
man
how how I wonder if you added up all the
[ __ ] you stolen in your life oh how much
that would be it's crazy and at that
time did you say Millions but really
coke yeah
whistling The Cove yeah yeah easy that's
crazy
easy yeah I was like Toba I worked for
him like from November to January that's
why I took my first page January 21st
1983 I took my first prince and mr.
Holloway Bell here my friend's dad Bell
Mia the kid I was telling about food
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so it's a small world that's crazy gonna
come bail me out and [ __ ] I was
supposed to do something I put a warrant
out for my arrest
and I got arrested like five years later
and Tenafly and they had to bring me
back to that place the answer for not
[ __ ] I forgot all about the van story
- with George me read in the [ __ ] van
you have no idea how many cars I blew up
blew up well that's why I caused pouring
in meny oh that poor car how many how
many tickets you think really like just
let me tell you something let me say my
side of this story and I'm upbeat and I
never used this term before
but it's gonna make sense to you guys
first of all how does LA welcome you buy
a ticket you don't really know what la
is till you park wrong in LA and get a
ticket $75
there's nothing worker in LA if you come
to LA and move here trust me the first
week you'll get it take ya they AB dit
it's something weird down there that
gives you a ticket my first experience
was they told Doug Stanhope his car oh
yeah I woke up with Doug Stanhope was
car when I was at Ralphie's all night
snoring Coakley [ __ ] we're [ __ ] a
bunch of people over there
there you go and I went outside and the
car was gone from sunset and Stanhope
was that some girl's house so I had to
go [ __ ] get it out before Stanhope
down-low
that's when he had the red Honda yeah
yeah yeah red Honda and then he had the
car you could borrow what street was he
curse on done curse on Mitch was on all
the arrow bow nice hair everyone need
you were on Vista
yeah and Ralphie and those guys were on
guard we were you with us at Mitch's
apartment when we when we were watching
his first Letterman set that was bananas
that little spot he had with his girl
his girlfriend at the time if it's
and I'm his girlfriend was helping you
her manager yeah she worked for a man
yeah yeah he had Barry Segundo look at
that
who the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with some novice [ __ ] oh gosh she had
Wendy Liebman Barry he had like three
stars at the time Barry Segundo no one
did anything amend or if I have to
[ __ ] testify people go to jail
I just remembers stupid [ __ ] there's a
gun now that's crazy Josh wolf 25
[ __ ] years just so people know we
were doing this [ __ ] in Seattle 25 years
ago now they took that away from us we
don't have this snowball no it's not
gonna come back for another six months
maybe
no but you know what though I mean look
you you're still you know I mean like
there's still things to do
yeah there's still things to differ one
there's a thousand hustles on that
[ __ ] computer okay these guys are the
panicking and going out look at my heart
goes out to Brendan Schaub and yeah I
made a [ __ ] up joke on Twitter but
those they both know I love him today
yeah yeah I called Brendan before this
whole thing started I go Brendan don't
go out there don't let nobody talk you
into going out there there's no reason
to go out there right now this was this
was when it was just Kovac
this wasn't but all this social yeah
[ __ ] going on right now right now it's
horrible to go up if you're going out
you got a 50-50 chance of coming back
that's the scrape scrape business so I
don't know if you know this Vegas was
gonna open up comedy yeah just
but when deal fainted they said that's
it so what's gonna happen now
that two or four comics actually got it
who's you know and that was my point
like why would you go to a comedy show
now everybody cancelled everything right
now and
in the midst of all the cities the
comedy clubs in question
Florida's comedy clubs Texas comedy
clubs in Arizona yeah you don't want to
be anywhere down there right now
you know I in my world and I'm a druggie
I come from that culture bars can't be
open sorry sorry that done bars cannot
be open because we have a hard time
social distancing as human yeah
nevermind an alcohol it's not gonna work
it's not gonna work let me tell you
something before this if you know
anything about me I don't like sitting
next to people when I go to a restaurant
unless is Dan Tana's or something like
that well you have to sit next to
somebody who accept it and they're on
top of you but you go there for the
steak you know I'm saying gonna Ralphie
takes yes I'm rethinking yeah yeah
remember Ralphie took us yeah dude - we
didn't take us to that one
he took it throw one up the block for
lunch and do you remember he had just
gotten one of his surgeries he took us
to the [ __ ] what was the one at the
corner that Dan Tana's but it wasn't no
he took this I T took us at Dan Tana's
one time but there was one up the corner
you walked in and they would give him
the back any in a big table yeah it was
a big table they were giving the back
room you would walk in that room you
remember how much he had just gotten one
of the surgeries and you remember how
much food he [ __ ] we got we went
there for lunch the tab was a nickel
yeah he was good don't forget looking at
that bill Gold $500 yeah [ __ ] lunch
yeah he was like there's no problem
Blair I got this I mean just look at
each other yeah holy [ __ ] and if he
didn't take you there he would take you
to the real the other sushi spot the one
I'm Beverly it costs $50 just to walk in
there you talk about the one near La
Cienega I'm Beverly yes yeah every time
I went in there he was he came to me one
night he's like man look at this he had
a picture with Clint Eastwood he bumped
in think I was in there with him one day
he would walk in and go they would you
know they bang a drum yeah you walk in
they go one might say and he would go
must be the money he would he would Joe
it must be the money we've seen the back
and he started ordering [ __ ] 30 our
roles and I'd be sitting there with four
hours of mine yeah just give me hundred
bucks I don't need all this [ __ ]
sushi and he'd [ __ ] all the sushi
might be sitting there the chick from
the [ __ ] the chick from roundish
that's now a big star every time I was
in there with him she would come in
there to pick up sushi to go she's in
the big chain now Ralphie was always
good like that though man oh he took
this to every restaurant yeah he was
gonna get probably like yeah it was over
yeah he was 600 pounds he didn't give a
[ __ ] and he did not like to eat alone
no he did not want to eat alone no Edie
and then he'd tell you taking home to
your wife ain't taking this [ __ ] on my
wife [ __ ] I take it this much too
cause this my way what it's fake [ __ ]
you but we would go to sushi damn and
cause damage yeah he took me to a sushi
spot next to the Comedy Store you know
there's a sushi spot next to Tommy star
he's another 52 just to walk in in the
hotel right next to the comedy store
there's a sushi spot bro they have these
little steaks on a stick
they started 20 I had to millionaires
take me there at one time
I've had two millionaires take me there
and they didn't even look at the bill
but they were too busy so I kept
ordering those things you don't design
like you don't take me to that place one
guy took me as a beard there one guy was
a friend of mine was a dear friend of
mine I haven't seen him in years this is
ten years ago and he calls me one day
he's like hey you hungry oh my god this
had to be 15 years ago this had to be
before the longest shard he goes wrong
because I had a big daddy warm-up suit
on they gave me a hard time
that's how I level that places he was
just meet me over there with you and I
babies with abroad and he was married
and I'm like what's going on Oh since
his chick I'm [ __ ] and just play cool
so she sat next to me and he sat next to
me so I sat in between so he's talking
behind my back and I got the Japs here
I'm like you can keep bringing those
steaks 20 apiece and I was dipping them
in that sashimi sauce whatever [ __ ]
whatever it was it was phenomenal where
is it on Sunset I mean right next door
right next to the store there's a fire
outside and walk upstairs you've been
there I know exactly where you talk that
place in there it's a yardstick just I
don't think that was a hotel so I went
there like huh I went there like in 2003
with this millionaire and I was like the
sushi was fresh they would kill him head
over there you could pick the fish out
of the pond and [ __ ] and then Ralphie
Ralphie must have dropped and the table
was [ __ ] back sushi yeah like it was
just you can't even explain to people
like they wouldn't even understand like
people go that's unnormal but before he
hit I remember driving to
jack-in-the-box with him he was like
Josh wolf come up I mean he was getting
jack-in-the-box for people in the
building right and he put two orders in
one was huge and the other one was like
a burger and fries and I go what's the
small bag for he goes this is what this
is what I going to eat on the way to
that apartment oh he goes yeah my other
foods in the bag I was like okay and he
goes we open up the glove box I go yeah
my man had condiments yet hot sauce yeah
yeah the red one the purple one
we had everybody different color sauce
in there now wasn't that car a thousand
yeah he was so heavy in that car he
[ __ ] the shocks up yeah I agree with
that the shocks were like this he gave
that car away and the car was through
sideways but he would have you think I'm
[ __ ] kidding you he would but here's
the thing about Ralphie you still
remember him giving you a bag of candy
to take home Tony yes yeah with this one
he was broke yeah well he was broke he
would still go I'm a been gone man with
Josh wolf ain't coming to my house I
don't know what Josh what was that and
he's like I bought us kids a bag of
candies and you know what like my heart
broke he didn't have a hundred bucks to
give you kids mhm but he had candy for
ya that was a type of duty was you know
that kind of I was thinking by the time
we were at the pool he was get dude we
were at the pool and you asked me where
the weed was hidden and you spelled it
out dr aw and I was like what it's a
[ __ ] drug that's not how you spell it
yeah you I made you say it twice like a
1 you it's in the dr aw I'm like what
are you saying to me because I couldn't
yeah
then we're in Seattle and we move I'm
moving with you and listen how weird was
that though I mean would people
understand you know the people that walk
in that bill would you please tell these
people what about them you've got what
can I build and get your dick sucked at
4:00 in the morning and it was crazy
morning you get your dicks what about D
you gonna have an orgy in that building
affordable what about the lesbian couple
that did heroin that's not a holiday and
and the white porno chick next to her
the the lesbian couple used to sell
those steaks where were those Omaha
Steaks but they used to take heroin so
the steaks would go bad in their
apartment and it would [ __ ] smell you
have no idea you have no idea what we
saw at 9:07 there are couple of drug
dealers in that bill that was - drug
dealer white
mm-hmm there was the Jew white lightning
the Mexican kid yeah it's still around
he is he's still around
he's still at the rainbow come on go to
the rainbow he's out there with white
head it's up to his ass now
oh yeah [ __ ] you have to chicken that
white lightning sold drugs but he's
never balls to hide it in this house so
he would hide in the garage
which I dipped into many at times and he
was also highly at the chicks house with
no chin that big tents with no channel
tremendous tits like when you saw at the
pool I know you like look at those
titties but when she turned around there
was no chimney take over here like this
yeah you like how she gonna suck my dick
with no chin this is not good for people
you never say what you gotta do
rubba with our boats was he do it but
she was a dynamite person she was great
she was a great and a lot of she was if
she was a lot of fun yeah she got
building was a lot of fun at 4:00 in the
morning you had more of a chance of
getting your dick sucked and that and
doing heroin and coke at 4:00 in the
morning there then you did by going on
it was bananas in that for about a year
about a year it was a crazy building of
living it was that dude who lived right
below me with that giant giant walking
look your brother was you know I one day
by mistake this Rottweiler was like oh
my god it was like a like a you know
those the pictures of dogs in the
magazines that look like they have
actual muscles that one of those
[ __ ] he he was trained to kill
yeah he was training them to kill yeah
and next to the two hot heroin lesbians
was a chick who Gary wolf went out with
what about the dude who killed the
hooker with the sword who used to wear
the [ __ ]
he what he worked on Star Trek and so he
had Klingon
make up he was an extra but he was his
dream to be on the show so used to where
that he used to walk around in his robe
but he didn't take the [ __ ] mask off
and he would be this culling a-huntin it
is no idea that dude was [ __ ] crazy
that building the landlord was good
people
Maria Maria she's grabbed the chick who
ran the room in the belly woman with a
heart condition I just saw her on
Facebook I Cathy Lewis Cathy blue is
great that's thing yeah and she had an
open mic she was always very nice always
very nice yes that Hollywood building
till this day when I Drive by it
sometimes just to get goosebumps there's
a parking spot rice take and Manny's car
do like a grandma blow I remember one
night we got some coke with somewhere
and it was on fire and I was at Coach
and Horses with Fulton yeah Doug's name
though but I couldn't talk the ball was
bad and I couldn't talk I was so [ __ ]
up on this coke what am I gonna do I'm
only don't like five lines and I'm
[ __ ] up mmm I said [ __ ] it I left this
I'll be right back I pulled one of those
moves I was so [ __ ] up on coke it was
11 o'clock I can't even talk and I went
across the street to a liquor store they
just closed because they don't like that
old block down was next to curse on yes
at 11:00 I one time liquor store I
bought a six-pack and I walked a Vista
and I were walking to man mayonese car
and I still remember pulling the seat
back and doing little wines people
walking their dogs people walking past
me from el compadre oh yeah and I was
laying the seat back and I would do life
and I still remember being like 3:00 in
the morning I me putting like a jacket
on and lowering the sunroof I had the
sunroof and I would just jerk off little
jerks so somebody came by they wouldn't
see me jerking my dick that that dog you
can't write this [ __ ] right there on
Vista I would jerk off because it got to
the point that I couldn't
upstairs and be coked up cuz Malia would
jump on me with that coke I to give her
ad so I'm not giving nobody happy
there was some nights I give him only a
half and there was some nice that [ __ ]
was just too good hey thank you very
much for coming on tonight here 25 2014
years that's how it's just can't believe
that I'm doing comedy 29 years 18th it's
29 [ __ ] is I could stick with nothing
for two minutes yeah but listen man I
would tell you that anybody who's seen
you before this all went down and saw
you at the store like every bit of work
you've put in shows oh no that's I told
you it was weird this last year before
this happened I would find myself on
stage and gets them laughing and I would
go I would think about while I was on
stage telling the jokes I would thank
myself putting in the work like oh I
remember where I learned this I learned
this sad what was that casino that
triple one elko yeah
alcohol Nevada was a horror show alcohol
like I learned this at the underground
you know I think about comedy I think a
lot about Seattle I can give the Comedy
Store a lot of love but I give me a call
yeah and Ron and that whole scene you
know they gave us so much free Dodi you
know we had yeah you know and that's
what people said agree well I'm thinking
of starting Tommy in LA that's great but
I'll tell you what you're not because we
were not worried about headshots then
nobody talked about headshots we didn't
talk about a DVD stand-up we didn't talk
about specials we didn't talk about
agents we didn't talk about managers and
that's a very special thing when you
just doing stand-up
it's fun Monday lights how much fun what
you lived how much what did you make on
Monday didn't make it done no you went
down there because you were gonna eat
for free you were gonna drink for free
and you were gonna laugh your ass off
because we had 18 comics would go up
every Monday and Tuesday 10 of them
would be legit yeah the other eight but
funny were guys that were gonna pull the
trigger on themselves or somebody else
any day and today you look back a lot of
those guys iced himself the guy who's
come up with the handcuff on he did yeah
he was always a we though he was all
like don't act like I forget what his
name is God rest his soul I didn't know
but I mean I'm not surprised I was I
used to come up on stage yeah hang
casino like yeah yeah yeah
there was a lot there was one guy too
had a joke up there I mean one night I
walked in their highest [ __ ] I think
you know who this you I forget his name
good kid I think they used you mentioned
his name before I sat down AHA I'm
watching this guy headline and he goes
so he was talking about that rodeo clown
show what do you prefer or me I prefer a
finger yeah that was Joe Vespasiano
jovis Posey Ali first time I heard that
joke
I remember that you're the finger yeah I
[ __ ] fell the [ __ ] you know all those
my god I remember that bro you remember
all those jokes
he was a great writer he was a
phenomenal he was talking about the
rodeo climb something with a rodeo clown
that I was on a roll on and then he went
into the [ __ ] animal thing son what
are you preferable but all those years
of watching
we'll both hear and Brody is watching at
this podcast right now yeah
[ __ ]
I'm saying they can harvest or I don't
live my life that way my life that way
that way he kidnapped me he should be in
jail right now I just forgave him I
forgave him because he was good to me ah
because I saw him then he came good then
he came back you know I wasn't alright
so we moved to LA Brody was in New York
yeah and I'm a coach nurses one man
Brody walks so I'm with a girl and her
girlfriend and we start talking and also
this three o'clock running on through
drugs I think Brody's smoke pot yeah but
either smoke oh yeah so I'm smelling
coke with the two broads and Brody's
making the one broad laugh so we go [ __ ]
it let's go Brody you coming with us and
brace like what are you talking about I
know you drive the heels I'm not driving
I go you [ __ ] driving [ __ ] this get
in the car we got in the car
he's got the cassette in yeah for
Superunknown ha we get to the [ __ ]
building or I lived I lived on Hollywood
on the corner with all the Russian yeah
yeah the girl lived in the building next
to me and the other girl lived in the
bill we ended up in the girl's apartment
and then I left with the one girl and I
left Brody with the chubby blond but I
stole the cassette to Superunknown as
we're getting out of the car push things
and two nights later I see him at this
thought he's like can I ask you a
question do you know what happened to my
super unknown cassette and I go I got it
at my house because I love you I didn't
have to tell you anything I just loved
that out where you gonna be in the next
few we see you home I'm home and I'm
home that's it let's just check out the
YouTube channel my specials on there for
free you're beautiful you're the best
I'm happy baby you came up thank you so
much before we get out of here real
quick
Thank You Lee you're alright like
something you're finally in that I know
more yeah yeah yeah those farts brought
you back yeah see what happens when you
sniff farts it's good for you the church
is also brought to you by one of my
favorites zip recruiter during this time
change we want you to know that sip
recruiters focus has not changed they're
still doing what they've always done
helping people find work and they're
helping businesses find the right people
for the job if you're looking for a job
zip recruiter is working with you to
find the right job faster they're
dedicated to helping you get hired from
care taken to delivering food to goods
to build the medical facilities supply
and protective equipment and so much
more in fact zip recruiter app will send
you up to date job openings so you could
be one of the first to apply and if
you're actively hiring zip recruiter
will invite candidates to apply to your
most urgent roles making it faster and
easier to reach the people you need by
connecting people who need jobs and
companies that need people it's that
easy
zip recruiter is working with all of us
so we can keep moving forward you're
looking for a job you're looking to hire
the best quality candidate out there go
to zip recruit a la cama right let's
work together so bullets are Pakula
dot-com / work together right now
zip recruiter com / work together
I want to thank Josh wolf I want to
thank the what's that
Spotify Oh I want to thank don't forget
to watch us on Spotify I want to thank
Josh wolf want to thank the
[ __ ] but I want to thank you
guys for always having our [ __ ] back
it's a beautiful day to be alive there's
a lot of [ __ ] you could be doing but
you're listening to us [ __ ] thank
you very much for tuning in Lee kick
this [ __ ] meal we